is
zaka um applicable on money that you've
loaned out as far as money that is Lent
anything lent whether it is gold that is
given on loan or silver or money or
currency the person who owns that he has
to pay zakat on it though I know that
the one you have lent to but na without
any without interest that in Islam if I
lent to
someone then the person who owns it has
to pay and the person who uses it he
doesn't have to pay and you have to
calculate it for
example if you have given for a business
deal saying that we share the profit
then it is your money yet you have to
pay the zakat there are two types of
loan that are given one is secured loan
and the other is unsecured loan if you
give to one of your friends or
relatives
alone without any interest just for the
sake of Allah subhana
taala if it is a secured loan knowing
the person is Rich and return it to you
you have to pay zakat every year so if
you give it in about a couple of years P
maybe two or three years pass you have
to pay every
year the zakat on that amount if you
have lent 100,000 rupees
$100,000 then you have to pay 25,000
rupees or $25,000 every year on the
money you have lent every year if you do
not have the money the money you have
lent is all that you had and you cannot
pay zakat then when it comes back to you
if it come back to you after 3 years
then you have to pay for the 3 years
that is 3 into 2.5 you have to pay 7.5%
that's $75,000 or 7,000 rupees and the
other type of loan is an unsecured
loan where the person who you have given
to maybe poor and you have doubts
whether he will be able to repay the
money or not if it is unsecured loan and
if you feel that you may not receive the
loan you have given so if you don't want
to pay you need not pay every
year but if you don't get the money then
you not pay the zakat but if you get the
money maybe after 5 years then you have
to pay for all the years that you had
lent so if you paid for 5 years 5 into
2.5 that becomes 12 and a half% so you
pay 125,000 rupes or
125,000 on that amount